ben hmida ladies and gentlemen i am
very happy to welcome
josep borrell today as high
representative of the european union for
foreign affairs and
security policy and vice president of the
european commission
i am happy to welcome him because
d  first because he is a friend and
we have in the past many
opportunities to collaborate and both of
us valued each other and then I am
also happy to receive because we have
together to face many challenges and
in a world of  more and more
unstable more and more uncertain thus the
european union to remain master of its
destiny and not go out of history
it must defend and affirm its
sovereignty in many areas
and it must also give itself the
financial means
technological and political capacity,
it will be able to do so only by remaining united
and to do so only by remaining
ambitious, and the role of the High
Representative in this respect will be
the main thing and i have full confidence in
joseph bourrel to carry out this
mission with determination and will
it is no coincidence
that josep borrell was on his first
day in the cast present at the
ceremony of  tribute to our soldier who
died in mali and it is not a
coincidence he will participate in
the salt break summit on monday it will be both
a symbol but it is also obvious
because the role of the european union
and  key in many crises in
particular salt could simply
before giving him the floor reminded
but he knows it and remind you but
you also know how much
it is our collective security that is at
stake there it is our
security border in  truth it is also the
security of the countries concerned
of course it is also the condition for the
development of these regions of course
but it is also the security of the
european union the union is already doing a lot in
terms of development of fo  training
with the upm and you cap mission in particular
it does a lot if we support the
joint force also does a lot in
the presence of european countries in the
oussema mine the presence of
european countries in the barkan force
the announcement of the participation of
several countries  europeans of the
takouba task force but the
security deterioration in particular in mali and
burkina means that we need a
reinforced presence we must I think do
more and better better ensure the
deployment and coordination of
the defense and security forces in mali
more  close to the engagement zone better
train and support the armed forces
of the g5 better develop the missions
of the psdc throughout the sahel and
have the means to generate
sufficient force to assume its missions
we will talk a lot I think on Monday
and  I would like to welcome in particular
the desire expressed already hardly before
the Church Foreign Affairs of the
High Representative to put in  implements the
partnership for the security and
stability of the sahel the p3s it is a question of
both widening the scope of the
coordination of cooperation the
geographical scope but also the song of the
place of action and the perimeter of action
towards both the entire security apparatus
of the countries concerned and
to ensure that they have a framework
for mobilization and
global coordination but think that josette
will talk about it in a moment I would have
also said that we are  we talked about
the situation in iran we talked about
the situation in the gulf the situation
in ukraine is not all part
of the conversations of transparency that
we both want to have
during the mandate that was entrusted to josep
borrell of which I  am sure that he will ensure
with great force
when I wanted to greet him again
to express both my friendship but
also our determined will
let us work without mercy thank you very much
Minister
dear friend Jean  nive and I am really
delighted to have exchanged with your
[Music]
thoughts on the
international situation and on the problem that does not
affect France, its major
European countries and the European Union,
but we have found that we
share a common vision on the
need to address existing challenges
and future challenges together in an
effective way in a world
of power politics we need to think
and act like what the european union
wants to be a potion of global if you
remember that the president of  the
commission has defined this commission
as a political duo commission and
this means a certain capacity
to act on the plains of the world
starting with those who are no longer
close
and among those who are close to us there
is undoubtedly africa and
inside africa
the calls yesterday at the foreign affairs council
we launched the strategy
for africa which must culminated
in a partnership which will see  the light
and which will be ratified in the european union summit
and the african union over
the next year but first of all there
go she let she must become
a higher priority for dresses
for the european union france  plays
a leading role and a bmp of the
highest the folds of the highest
i have witnessed as i salute and to
the french soldiers at the court of the invalids
death to preserve the safety of
all europeans in the border site of
the  dress which is already it is managed
thank you to the president of the republic for
his invitation to participate
next week with presidents of
the sahel country
a dance and a new reflection which
will allow us content is more
to the security of these countries to  the stability
of this country and to the security of europe
the european union has three missions in the
sahel
a defense mission two
security missions we
must expand them i am going to present to the council
of ministers a  vin et rosières of
proposal in this direction so that
widen the geographical extent of
the territorial scope of this mission
and deepen its ambition so that
the cooperation of the mission is of
France in the task that his in
these countries that c  is a commitment that we
will develop in the next
council but I wanted to share the
dedicated ministers that I made
before with the minister of
defense
obviously from ukraine was present in
our conversations
I salute the efforts of france and
from germany in the formats normandy
gets dirty koné was able to establish 16
9th permanent ceasefire
a withdrawal of the engagement forces and
the exchange more at the nlhe and those of the
first steps to move forward in a
political solution to a  great
problems your dress that stability
and security in its border is
here sir thank you
again welcome me in wheel
marveled his name of the r  republic
comes very different from the king of brussels
a slightly more functional look thank you
we had planned for questions there are lots
of requests but sick since yesterday that
two questions to my questions on
lebanon could speak to questions
on lebanon tomorrow you welcome
senior officials on lebanon given that
the economic situation in lebanon lebanon
given that the economic situation is
deteriorating and the political situation is
not improving what is
what the international community that
france can do for for  stabilize
the banking sector especially in
lebanon and what message do you have for the
lebanese authorities who is
not really moving forward to solve their problem
is just an entry questions
about iran is what you are planning to
put sanctions on the pane
human rights in the coming weeks
given what has happened in the
last few weeks in iran thank you
very much on lebanon we have  ns
wished to take the initiative of the
meeting of the international
support group for lebanon which will meet here
tomorrow the goal is to encourage the
lebanese authorities both to become
aware of the seriousness of the situation
of their proposed to move forward  towards
reforms since the
Lebanese authorities Lebanese government will be
represented but also to become
aware of the call of the street and the
demonstrators who have been
meeting regularly since
October 17th so it is a
protest movement that is taking hold
over time  we must listen and
also ensure that the
Lebanese authorities can succeed in forming a
government quickly because any
delay will continue to aggravate the
situation and ensure that this
government can initiate the reforms
in this country we have
already met here  in april 2018
it was also on the initiative of
france in this context as part of what
was called cedar 2 av  ec
many actors and we had at that time to
mobilize significant amounts of
financial mobilization provided that
the necessary reforms can
be implemented and can be
found 3.10 billion dollars which
had been mobilized announced and for
the  moment we stayed there since neither the
reforms carried out the stability that
were there so it is a
kind of strong appeal that we are going to
make tomorrow to all
those who can act so that lebanon
can regain stability  on the
Iranian question
our immediate concern, which I
will be able to complete,
is to ensure that we
act for the maintenance of the jcp geese
and to alert the Iranian authorities to
the danger represented by the
successive violations of the agreement of
vienna which if it  was further
reinforced in January could
call into question the agreement itself and
we consider that this is a bad
answer to cert  is a bad
American decision on which we have
already had the opportunity to pronounce ourselves a
bad answer which is given
today and if the door to keep
the essence of the agreement of Vienna to
allow the serenity the stability of
the  region to have this configuration
any major break would lead to
threatening instability so we our
efforts are going in that direction but
his ministers on the book i cant
add anything what his views gentlemen
ministers said about iran and you
may have  noted the press release that
the european external action service
issued last week about the
events in iran and the
continent's sister was with very strong language
to clearly expose the
condemnation of the european union to the
repression that  takes place in lyon
in proportions absolutely the group
is unacceptable
from our side and you must express my
satisfaction for the fact that the meeting
in vienna showed  that there is still a
chance of saving the nuclear agreement
there was unanimity among the countries represented
under the coordination of the
european union and that we hope to be able to
convince the iranian authorities
is not to endanger the survival of
this  European bruno agreement is very very
important but for the moment
yesterday at the foreign affairs council
there was not on the table a
sanction proposal allying hear
year to iran for the repulsion of
which took place in recent days those  I
am not going to say that she had judged
does not marry to be approached with a
hard effect a second question what to charm
her miracles I am sorry because we
have a schedule a little a little
against a former minister sir
hello  and tax assistance for the
bloomberg news agency questions for
you do you consider the
meeting that took place yesterday
mr morel to be significant progress
the meeting in normandy format
was that progress  incremental Is
it significant for you
Is it possibly
leading to a lifting of
European sanctions vis-à-vis Russia and
France plans to have a new
security and stability architecture
for the  europe and which is heading in particular
towards russia with diplomatic work
towards russia and what
is your opinion on this architecture
proposed by the French president is
that something that you
also want to defend is
that something  that you support
thank you I started then you drive I
start on the first part of your
question regarding what happened what happened
yesterday first first it happened because
a meeting in nomadic format  it had
not taken place for three years because at
each of the initiatives taken
proposal made by
both germany and france
there was no possibility on
the other side
so this union was p  assé it
was undoubtedly facilitated by the initiatives
taken by the president and nasri in
particular to allow the opening of
three crossing points there were
also exchanges of prisoners so that there
were small gestures that were
accumulated and which
reinforced other small gestures which created the
conditions for this meeting to take
place
then it enabled progress,
you reminded us, a researcher is
just now in the field of almost the
immediate life of the Ukrainians at the
once on the exchanges of prisoners on
the ceasefire first on the
exchanges of prisoners on demining
the opening of three additional crossing points of
which we were in
one we returned to a purely
positive logic with progress each time
it is important now
that under the control of the water has had these
advances can be made a reality and there
is a certain urgency since one
in particular commitments of eco
hanging prisoners in the concept all
identified for all identified is done
before the end of the year
and then beyond that it will be necessary to continue to
address the political issues
linked both to the status of the region of Donetsk
and by far what is also linked to the
implementation of the political and
security part of the minsk agreements is
also linked to the integration of the
stand better formula in Ukrainian legislation
also linked to the recovery of
borders by the Ukrainian political authorities
all of this is obviously in
front of us but we  we are on a
positive path to address them
, especially since it has been decided
to have a new meeting in
Normandy format and in four months,
therefore, there is a relative acceleration of the
process, which means that we are in
a positive spiral,
we must  preserve it
thank you the european union reaffirms its
support for france to germany for
its work in the so-called fort my
normandy to address the issue at the
kenya it is an initiative of these two major
european countries that the european union
supports because we are convinced that
the only lasting solution to the conflict
with ukraine in ukraine and
russia can only come from dialogues that
have started in this  format and that any
substantial change in
relations with
russia bands to find a
lasting solution to the conflict
that said I must welcome the progress that
has taken place in this meeting
it's not bad it's not two things to
see stop  fire on the entire line
of engagement it is no small thing
to proceed again with the disengagement of the
forces which are facing the south two
other exchanges of prisoners and
her friend born undoubtedly an
improvement in the living conditions of the
inhabitants of two  sides of the line of
contacts it is not beforehand to
continue the political dialogue towards the
plain
the plain of satisfaction of the
minsk agreements and from this point of view my
congratulations the fra  nce germany for
this meeting which, as the minister
said, had the merit of existing and of being
a first step towards the solution of the
conflict
the relationship with russia depends
critically on finding a
solution to the conflict with  ukraine
without that there will be no changes
in the sanctions established by the
european union vis-à-vis russia
thank you very much